On January 9th, North and South Korea engaged in high-level talks for the first time in two years.
Instead of addressing North Korea's nuclear program,
the two sides discussed less contentious issues, such as North Korea's participation
in the upcoming Winter Olympics in Pyeongchang.
While dialogue can reduce unnecessary tension, and even serve as a way to gather more information
about North Korea's perspectives and strategy, there could be drawbacks if Washington and Seoul are not careful.
First, North Korea's willingness to talk about minor issues is not an indicator
that Pyongyang's position on nuclear weapons is softening.
There is no situation under which North Korea gives up its nuclear weapons through negotiations.
Second, Kim might be trying to improve relations with Seoul as a way of driving a wedge in the US-ROK alliance.
And there's a risk of this, given that the United States prefers a strategy of escalating pressure
whereas South Korea prioritizes maximum engagement.
Now more than ever the United States and South Korea must continue to coordinate their approach towards North Korea.
What do you think about the potential thawing of relations between North and South Korea?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.